se abre un nuevo capítulo de las
tensiones entre el líbano e israel
después de que fuerzas israelíes hayan
bombardeado esta madrugada el sur de
líbano el primer ataque israelí que se
recuerda desde el conflicto de 2006
entre estos dos países vecinos
técnicamente en estado de guerra el
incidente fronterizo responde a una
serie de lanzamientos de cohetes desde
suelo libanés de los que todavía ningún
grupo se ha responsabilizado la zona
atacada en el líbano es la ciudad de
marjayoun donde se encuentra la segunda
base más importante de las fuerzas de
paz de la onu la miguel de cervantes
donde hay soldados españoles y latinos
la nueva escalada de tensión ocurre en
un momento en el que el líbano atraviesa
la peor crisis económica de su historia
sumado a la inestabilidad política ya
las críticas internacionales por la
falta de colaboración de las autoridades
libanesas en la investigación por la
explosión del puerto de beirut el líbano
ha anunciado hoy que llevará el caso
el consejo de seguridad de la onu porque
es una clara violación de los
compromisos por parte de israel- del
acuerdo de alto el fuego alcanzado para
poner fin a la guerra de 2006